Hey look there's a flock of cows herd of
cows that herd of them there's a whole
flock right there you know people say
they pick their nose yeah I feel like I
was just born mine you know what
flamingos sleep with one leg pulled up
if they pull both legs up they fall over
hold on I'm coming in my shoes I'm
pretty sure it's a foot dad make me a
sandwich
poop you were saying what's the
difference between a tuna a piano and a
pot of glue I don't know what you can
tune a piano but you can't piano a tuna
well what about the glue I knew you get
stuck there why was 6 afraid of 7
because 7 ate 9
because 7 was a registered sex offender
and there's nothing funny about that
why do chicken coops have two doors
because if they had four they'd be a
chicken sedan ha ha ha
Pete and repeat are sitting on a fence
Pete falls off he's left 3 Pete Pete and
Reid Pete are sitting on a fence
Pete falls off he's left repeat Pete and
repeat are sitting on a fence Pete falls
off now who is left you get it you get
it
Tommy's doing it again go to your room